welcome to the special unesco world
philosophy day version of dr. sailors
philosophy form we have a lot of cool
stuff to discuss today I've got my
special guest Leandra Lima the founder
inventor designer of innovative new
platform truth score we're going to talk
a lot about that today we're also going
to talk about critical thinking and the
culture that we live in and I'll put in
a plug for my my own new critical
thinking channel I decided you know that
since it is world philosophy day and
critical thinking such an important part
of philosophy these would fit in well
together if you like with all these
google hangouts on air if you want to
ask us questions we have the
question-and-answer app-enabled on the
Google+ event page so we already have
one question if you want to weigh in
with more questions or comments that's
great you can upvote each other's
questions or comments and we'll take the
ones that have the most plus ones first
we're not going to be watching Twitter
and YouTube and these other feeds
because it's just me and Leandro doing
it today so if you want to engage us the
way to do it is through the Google+ app
like I said it's a world philosophy day
and so word about that first the United
Nations declared world philosophy day
about a decade ago and it's it's
commemorated each year so this is the
one day of the year where we get to you
know do some rah-rah for for philosophy
I've already released a video about
doing philosophy in a public way a
little bit earlier there's a lot of
other cool events going on actually a
lot of them are over now because you
know the ones in Europe it's nighttime
but you know there's there you go that's
world philosophy day let me introduce
Leandro I've mentioned that he is the
founder of truth score so once he starts
talking you're going to see his his
young you know visit on here so go ahead
Leandra say submit everyone watching um
my name is Leandro and the founder of
truth score for those of you who have
don't know anything about it it's a
basically a social and educational
website that really attempts to organize
the way we communicate with each
and really the way we are the way we
argue with each other the way we we
disagree with each other so that's my
goal is that we uh we have a great
through as it as a society and that we
could really unite instead of bicker
about you know left right up down and
different things we bicker than one so
um that's a good segue into something
but but I a question occurs to me that i
didn't put into this this why is it so
important to change the tone of argument
or debate in our current society in your
view because i know that's part of what
truth scores about it is i think i think
a lot of the world's problems right we
have we have the internet now we have
these breakthroughs in technology but
but those breakthroughs I don't think
have really made an amazing difference
in how we how we organize our society
you know from from us politics to global
politics it politics is where our lack
of communication and our inability to
unite as one group or at least a
stronger universal voice about our
society it's still really lacking in my
opinion people are dying they're still
there are Wars going on all over the
world and and it doesn't seem to be
getting better and I don't see really
any tools that really helped us there no
significant tools yeah you know one of
the things that we talked about again
we'll get back to anything to tell us
more about truth score in a second I
want to know about I have a question but
your desk or two okay well you know I
remember going to this II democracy
forum this is about you know six seven
years ago and one of the big issues that
they're talking about what the internet
was the formation of silos where people
are only listening to those who see
things the same way you can see this on
Facebook you can see this on Twitter
echo chamber white with dating sites
where people will actually say I will
only did a Democrat or I only did
Republican don't give me anybody well
and so the kind of site that you've
developed here that allows people to not
just you know put out their ideas but
have to say why they think that they're
they're justified and then see each
other's ideas and engage them it's one
way to try to break out of these these
silos that
internet I don't want to say it puts us
in it but it facilitates that it does it
does um you know I've heard it called be
called like the echo chamber oh yeah
yeah yeah heard you know my Google+ feed
is my personal echo chamber for all
sorts of political views that are I
think a unique or usual or in common i
should say and it's my echo chamber i
accept that and i like it you know I I
do get some thrill and inclusion by
going there and hearing and seeing all
the things that I like all things I
agree with um Facebook and all those
places right you tend to they promote
the things you like makes sense when we
go to a store or movie we want to see
what we like so they are they are giving
us what we want so this is a will to
break out of that a bit yeah there's a
TED talk as well that talks about that
actually maybe we can link it in the
video later on that explains this it's a
it's like the bubble of likes like the
echo chamber yeah I think it's great to
have that but but we really don't have a
place where we can really talk um more
seriously not even about what we like
what is it that we like and don't like
and why that's the key thing as the why
so why don't you ask me your question
about UNESCO and then war it's more
about philosophy um it's a real general
question may not even be a fair question
what you being someone who's a professor
who's who's taught philosophy was you
know seeing people struggle with it and
people take it on and change their lives
um what to you personally maybe or two
people you know why is philosophy so
important you know for those that see it
is important why would you say it's
important for those that don't see it is
important you know can you persuade them
a little bit in recognizing supports
yeah that's that's a that's what is a
fair question um I think that one part
of answering it is to say that sometimes
people are doing philosophy without it
being recognized as is doing such so
there's a lot of because of the way our
disciplines have have fallen out there's
a lot of people doing philosophy in
political science departments or English
departments history departments there's
like you know if I want to study Alexis
de Tocqueville who's a philosopher it's
very hard to study in the philosophy
you go over to Paul poli-sci or american
studies or something like that so
there's a lot of philosophy that's going
on without people recognizing it as that
discipline partly also because the
people who've been doing philosophy a
lot of them have professionalized it to
such an extent that it's it's it's
become boring and and and so abstract
too many other people you know that the
video that I released today for a world
philosophy day it was specifically about
doing philosophy in public ways
practical ways in popular ways because
there's this conception that if we're
doing that we're kind of we're kind of
um dumbing it down you know where we're
we're not doing really but you know
Socrates he didn't you know you didn't
have a degree he didn't go around and
say show me your degree before I talk to
you you know let me have your [ __ ] yeah
it's been role in my class he went up to
people and he talked to them and there
was back and forth discussion that he
didn't always you know produce his best
arguments for people that he you know
thought were you know heavy hitters that
these plato shows us that but he was
willing to to engage other people and so
I for me losophy um at least the way it
was classically done has always had this
very practical element to it right a lot
of a lot of great philosophers have had
gained jobs you know where they would
they would do something that was
productive you know Machiavelli was a
public official Aristotle was was a you
know physician at one point two and a
tutor so you know these are people who
modeled for us what philosophy could be
like unfortunately I think a lot of our
professors are even remotely like that
you know I'm sure it's some professors
don't even like philosophy if that's
impossible do you mean some of the
professors who teach philosophy like you
don't really they don't have a passion
that really makes a difference that is
actually the case and I won't do
anything like naming names but I'll say
that I've met plenty of people who
really like this little tiny bit it's
are like somebody I mean
to chef right chef who says I only like
cheese and the only cheese that I like
is chatter and so the only thing I'm
ever gonna cook with is cheddar cheese
you wouldn't hire somebody like you if
you like get the hell out of here what
are you what are you not a chef but but
that's the way it is for a lot of people
in philosophy i think you know i'm
picking on philosophy there it's that
way in a lot of other fields yeah a lot
of other fields um yeah philosophy yeah
I mean I've only after researching and
reading a lot about things that interest
me um did I notice that I was
interesting philosophy I didn't know it
was philosophy till you know all the
years after I really started to get into
it and I just enjoy it what am I going
to do no I had the same experience um I
never intended to become a philosophy
professor and if you'd told me when I
was in you know high school that that's
what I would be doing first I was I
don't plan on going to college so I
don't know how you figure I've got to be
a professor but um you know the idea of
doing something like this would just you
know took one philosophy course in high
school it was terrible and that
should've turned me off forever but it
was like what you're talking about you
know you you're questioning your
reasoning or you're saying why about
things and you don't realize that that's
that's integral to the disc awesome two
thinkers gain for sure yeah so tell us
about truth score you know what what's
the the sort of thumbnail overview of it
then we'll talk about some of the
details a bit later yeah so the
thumbnail overview one of the ways to
look at it is you know first of all
we've all had water pool discussions
we've all had conversations and family
or friends about what we don't look
about a political topic that's one of
the most common but it could be about
anything and I think the most one of the
common experiences that I've had that I
wanted to kind of cure when I was
brainstorming truth score is there's
that rare situation where you you either
read a book or saw you know lengthy
documentary you saw something that
really persuaded you and and you really
have strong beliefs about a certain part
of the thing you're talking about right
this Apple you're talking about for
example and then you're having a
conversation with someone and you can't
really get at them
is it's a very emotional conversation
there's a lot of there's a lot going on
in the conversation and you can never
really pin them down to try to get them
to see something new into conversation
it's not even about forcing anybody it's
just about giving it some light writes
about seeing something new you haven't
seen before and I had the trouble for
years with friends and family I do like
to argue you know and argues that even
the right word it's really discussed
it's converse but most people also
recognize it as argument which is like a
breakdown of communication I'd say um in
the everyday sense so long story short
um truth score tries to kind of solve
that you know it it allows people to
have like a simulation of a discussion
about opposing views and it tries to
harness the different points that that
would actually persuade someone this way
or that way because every time has
points they're usually the talking
points in it comes to politics it's the
points that keep people firmly on one
way or the other way and it's those are
the usual two points that can can have
someone budge and that's what route
score offers it offers the people who
who know and who have the the evidence
and the argumentation and the logic
reasoning reasoning being a keyword
behind something they really have an
opportunity to put it all together and
connect the dots in a way that anyone
can navigate um and I'm going to give
one more example although i think i
might be beating the course that feel
free to tell me that you know if you
just pick up a book you know a book is
just a string of sentences right as a
construct which is a programming term
it's a construction truth score is the
same thing except that it just organizes
how the constructions made for easy
navigation and with the purpose to
actually prove a certain thing true yeah
that I think that's a good way to put it
talk a little bit about what users
encounter when they get into truth score
you well ultimately truth sewer the
topmost element in truth score is what
we call a topic and so we're used to
Facebook posts in Google posts and
tweets right we used to these little
tiny and I say tiny because they're
usually small they're short bursts of
information memes right memes being
those pictures with words on top of them
with a certain message those short um
short messages that are that are
contagious nearly yeah they're um those
are the topics basically right which are
the subject matter what we're talking
about it be you know to use something
political that Obama broke a certain
promise or that bush broke a certain
campaign promise for example no they
break a promise your two or more than
that we can prove that we can prove that
I think beyond a reasonable doubt in
some cases in some cases we could just
make a really great case for it and so
those are the topics those are the main
elements and so when you just come on
they see the topic at the top and then
there's the two sides and it's no it's
important to say this is I think
somebody already at of East 89
how is it different than a 40 well a
forum is really the simulation of a
conversation in a conversation is you
speak I speak you speak I speak you
speak I speak you speak I speak ya soon
clenched all this has a different
structure to it we got a little better
with like Reddit where you can actually
reply underneath right so you can pretty
much segment off a new conversation that
a new dimension if you will it's a
really wonderful idea to do that and it
can get a little hairy but it's also
very useful but it's still the same
basic premise of you talk I talk you
talk I talking to talk I took you to
Pride Rock with some votes maybe so you
can see the things are more popular
truth scores different in that the
things that fall below the topic or the
replies if you would like a form there
they're actually intended to be what's
called the test of reality which is an
aspect of the topic that that you
believe is real that you believe has
substance you know so it's relevant that
contributes to it just yeah yeah
actually I way or the other exactly i
mean the test of reality should be
something where if you were to remove
that from reality it's like it's gone if
it wasn't real at all the topic couldn't
be real so it's like you know like the
building over of a building that the
steel of the building you take the steel
out the building is down it's a
different form it's no longer what it
used to be sort of like saying so the
topic is an assertion something is the
case and then you go a little bit lower
than that and you've got the tests of
reality and there could be anywhere from
one to twenty two hundred of these over
time and some of them are for saying
here's why you ought to accept this this
claim and some of them are again saying
here's something else and this goes
against that that claim and then it
looks really cool about it is you know
you've got other stuff below that so
it's not just write clearly correct
correct um wait thank you for that
that's a good segue so if you only are
having a conversation about something
controversial I might ask you a question
like well do you believe so in you know
i don't use any examples because it gets
political and people get turned off yeah
you know do you believe um do you think
that could have happened let's just use
a fake example which is at the gym
killed calm like a murder case
yeah so if you're free to suggest went
to so in a case like Jim killed Khan um
you know Khan has to be dead is khan
dead that's a pretty serious test of
reality if you can if you can I can walk
walk walk down the room open a door and
full con out of a room he's talking to
you is that going to persuade you that
he that the gym didn't kill con you sure
out and say yeah so that doesn't prove
anything that's just a test of reality
it's just a it's just a segment that
would persuade you so although there may
be hundreds of tests of realities for a
topic really there would only probably
be a dozen or half dozen then most
people would be willing to to be
persuaded by or so that's good that's a
good point talk a little bit about the
function of the score you know what's
the score in truth score the voting that
yeah the voting plays a big part in it
and one of the biggest things that tweet
score does is it does break a
conversation down discussion that you
would have with someone or a group of
people it breaks it down into many many
different segments so you can focus on
what each segments and tensions it my
intentions is intentions are so with the
voting so let's say that we have this
test of reality that you know is content
right if he's dead clearly there's
there's a higher chance that Jim killed
him which don't know yet right so um by
people voting that this would certainly
prove it wrong right and it would help
prove it right people make that judgment
call which is like it's a judgments not
really even a score but it's a judgment
for those that vote that this would
actually prove it certainly wrong it's
like without a doubt that pretty much
says that gives it a really that test a
reality a high score for the negative so
here's a good question that that came up
a long time ago when we're having
discussions about this but I think it's
one that a lot of people when they
encounter the platform for the first
time are going to ask are you as are you
actually measuring the truth of things
is that what the score is Intendant oh
no we're not measuring the truth because
truth is also very personal you can't
really truly measure truth truth is
something kind we make up in her own
mind right sometimes you can just look
at live with them killed tom you can
polke on out and say hey look at that
you know yeah um yeah people may not
want to believe it even if Connors right
there you know we've seen we've seen
weirder things happen in our society I
think um but I lost my train of thought
of scoring the truth know what people
are really scoring is their scoring how
well a test of reality bears on the
topic we're judging how if we accept a
piece of evidence for example if we
think a logical construction is is sound
which means which is a debate term which
means that it's built correctly that it
does make sense so what we're basically
doing is is giving the community an
opportunity to communicate to the people
who are contributing so I'm going to you
and me and other people the thinkers of
the world's website and the contributor
the contributors and the the community
at large will judge you know the weight
that tests the realities have and then
this is actually a good point to
actually to take one of the questions
yeah and he out of this 89 actually
rolled a whole bunch of questions into
one block and I'm only going to take one
part of this but it's something I was
gonna sort of you know steer you towards
talking about anyway um you've got this
platform and you're allowing people to
vote on controversial topics and to vote
on what counts as good evidence or
what's relevant you know how are you
going to keep people from just saying
hey come over here and vote for me he's
got he's asking about spammers and
trolls and that's my question but
patrols you know they're you know this
is one of the problems with reddit is
you you get some communities where
people just downvote stuff because
they're a bunch of jerks you know or
they don't like a particular topic it's
one reason why I you know I looked at
reddit and i was like i am not going to
get involved with you know too much work
to make my case there so how are you
going to keep that from from happening
I've got a few ideas you're talking to
background and website development and
programming and so the fight to keep
spammers and trolls out or at least
dude is it's like the neverending fight
right it'll happen forever it's
basically why we have police and society
to keep out the burglars and the people
who make us unsafe the spammers and
rollers are basically that the thieves
and the and the crooks of the of the
internet they ruin our experience so
that's that's that's it always a battle
but but still on answer questions so
there's a few techniques that already
are well established that lets the
community lock and flag those users
that's just one way but I think that
more broadly speaking right instead of
it besides using those common techniques
you also may have like an amazing great
number of people who have one view I
think that the Apple the question so
they become the trolls so let's just see
you know uh let's just use a you know a
fanatical religious right group right
the fringe group right so they may have
you know they mate what's let's say
you're discussing something having to do
with homosexuality all right of course
that no it's a very small church that I
forget the nod back back oof I have in
my mind Baptist say they they were
twenty times as big and they were angry
into the internet you know and and they
say well truth score we're going to make
sure that any topic that comes up along
these lines we you know upvote
everything that's on our site and
download everything that's on the other
side you're not um that's still that's
still good at that can still happen
that's I'm sure that's going to happen
um this is not a feature in critical yet
because it's in prototype mode but but
what we have we've been developing to
kind of resolve that it's not really a
resolve that the reality is when someone
disagrees about certain fundamental
ideas um whether they agree or disagree
whatever judgment they make the judgment
becomes public meeting all the other
users can see what judgment they made
and so that judgment gets recorded so
it's almost like me saying I don't know
Christmas trees are prickly for whatever
reason I I think that it's important for
me to say that to win my argument or
have my side by side this team and I can
I can go on the record saying that
there's no trouble and people will agree
some people will agree with me yeah but
it's just the more we do that the more
we distance ourselves from reality I
think and its recorded that way I think
the further we get from the people who
are
in the real you know so here we're
actually the answering and others what
I'm putting that question up there
Atavist 89s question is truth score
anonymous so the answer to that is is in
a sense it is because unless you
actually belong to the community you
know if you're not if you're not on the
platform you can't see what people are
writing but once somebody is entering
Christmas trees are prickly and that's
why I like Christmas it's out there well
if users one revise what they've said
the Khmer can they take it badly revised
and you know you get you get a letter
you get a lot of points for that not
physical points you get a lot of credit
for that because enlightenment this is
the path to enlightened although you
could be changing it to something that
works less for you yea though it that's
our goal to to change the context for
what it is to be wrong and change it
towards an Enlightenment conversation
you know I think one of the the issues
too this is something that we did talk
about as far as like keeping you know
sort of a preponderance of too many
people of this view or that view coming
in and messing up the numbers is we're
inviting can you can we call it a beta
test the sort of the pool yeah I'm
coming to prototype because it still has
a little bit to go okay you opened up in
it yeah so it's not or no type is by
invitation only at physically that's
right now I've suggested a number of
people in the critical thinking
community some of whom you know maybe
kind of far out on this this side that
side on some issues but presumably there
should be sort of like a good enough
critical mass of people who are you know
they're gonna they're gonna vote where
some measure of common sense would go so
that once it opens up for the whole
general public there's already a little
bit of a you know balance in place it's
sort of like putting ballast into a you
know a canoe you know to keep it from
from Terra well I think um you know the
bet we're biased on that back on that
balance right we're automatically biased
than that i think i think if you start
making some choices about some fun too
mental judgments on truth score about
the world and how it is you may have to
make a similar judgment in another place
for another topic yeah right and so this
this this is up on the conversation of
what's real it's not real um people who
really are out to just prove their point
and and and ignore reason and all those
different items in logic they're going
to eventually contradict themselves not
necessarily all the time but there's
going to be moments where they actually
contradict themselves in the same
judgment they're making and truth score
is going to catch that and so if you're
saying Christmas trees are prickly you
know on December December and then and
then you know months later you have a
conversation and you think they're not
prickly hold on a minute they can't be
both quickly and not quickly yeah you
have to actually make a choice and so
you have to pick which of these
arguments you're going to sew arguments
are going to change you know things are
going to what's considered truth untrue
score the score is going to change based
on how much you how much you progress
and users who only contribute a little
bit just to be right about certain idea
and then up contribute much more the
weight of their rationality which we
also measure the weight of their
contribution is diminished so the weight
baked they themselves pull on that topic
is diminished yeah that's that's a good
way to address that too one of the
things if you don't mind just finish off
that question there's two questions in
one there anonymous um it says anonymous
it's really not anonymous because truth
square will have your email address and
that's as anonymous as you want to be
right you can have an email address that
we have nothing to no care in the world
about so it says anonymous as a YouTube
or Twitter where you do have to register
with an email address so that we can
contact you but you can have a username
that yeah doesn't tie to your
personality at all so you can be
anonymous in that sense okay login yes
yeah that makes that makes good sense is
there is there going to be any way to
keep people from having you know a whole
bunch of multiple accounts there's no
true way to do that um um I think the
only yeah there's no real way to prevent
that I think
if you're going to have multiple
accounts you still flog into each
account and make judgments on things and
so you're actually you know I work and
yeah let's say you gonna spend two hours
I'm truth score week if you really want
to get something done like that you
wanted like troll around you're gonna
have to you have to do more of that you
know yeah it's possible there's no doubt
about that yeah yeah it's like it's like
with security you can't keep everyone
out but if you make it best attend or
addressed to you know Rob the store that
you're probably not going to get robbed
yep the lowest let's indulge ourselves a
little bit in talking about the sort of
backstory for for the project and how we
got to you know collaborating one of the
things that I never did ask you was when
you first got the idea for it what's the
what was the timeline for this um let me
try to remember it was quite a few years
ago funny enough um it must have been a
minutes 14 now it must have been two
thousand and four or five it's like nine
or ten years ago um maybe even a little
longer than that the back story is that
i did a paper in speech class for
college so actually we must have been
2002 either way i did a paper on the
collapsible trade center and you know i
did a lot of research and i watch the
PBS videos and you know the official
story was great and it was it was
fantastic i explain how the collapse
happened based on the official story a
few years later so a few years later
when i was reading online and
enlightening myself i discovered quite a
different story about the world trade
center right and when I discovered when
I did the research and I I mean I I
learned a little bit of physics to
understand what the research was saying
I really gave it a shot and I think I'm
a little cognitive dissonance for those
that note that is right when you get
frustrated or angry when you have
contradicting ideas in your mind um I
don't suffer from that as much as most
other people which is a weird
competitive thing to say um but but you
know I was able to break free of that
and I really started to you know some
people call it a conspiracy theory it's
all crazy I wanna get
that right now but when I started when I
started to realize that something as as
something related to physics something
related to math and science could go so
poorly understood by so many people in
the world on stand up on a topic of such
serious nature right which is people die
a lot going on there that's when that's
when I I had to do something you know
that's when that's when I started to
look I was also picking up debate and
argumentation and I was interested in
that and I'm like you know what I can't
believe this i can't believe that i
can't talk to people about it i can't
believe that i can't enlighten people
and i wanted to break 3 of that and i've
been working for about 10 years and both
conceptually and now of course
programming it to make that happen to
give people an opportunity to
communicate yeah you know there's
something about having to actually put
your your reasoning to map it out to put
it out there that tends to neutralize
the emotions you know that allows people
to have a certain distance and say oh
maybe I am a bias perfect when it comes
to this this sort of thing and then to
be able to engage other people i think
you know another good thing about this
certainly is somebody who teaches
critical thinking I could see using this
in class for my students so that not
only do they have to do the practice of
mapping out arguments instead of just
making claims um they get to see what
other people what their reasoning
processes are and they can say oh you
know I never thought about that because
most of us you know we we have there
might be 20 ways to get to point a and
we find the one that works for us and
that's all we think about but then you
see some other ones and you're like oh
that's now I actually understand point a
a hell of a lot better correct correct
correct there's that that herd mentality
that that exists for us right yeah I
think I think when people so let's go a
little bit deeper right so you have a
test of reality you can't imagine it
being true you can't even fathom it it's
preposterous to consider something like
that right so although you don't you you
would be persuaded um you don't believe
it so you go into the test of reality
and kind of expand it
and in the test of reality itself so now
we're not looking at the topic anymore
but we're looking at the test of reality
that's where people can contribute as
much evidence reasoning logic
connections that they want to to try to
make that one little part of that point
to try to support the topic yeah so
that's where that's where the good stuff
is that's where we get people focused
imagine a forum or a or a you know
Facebook post just the communication
where everyone's trying to really go and
prove one very specific idea in many
different ways yeah you know so there's
a for the whole universe of them true
score grated I particularly that into
this topic you can go over to this topic
correctly yeah let me ask you another
sort of backstory question oh this is a
pretty ambitious project nom what gave
you the confidence that something like a
whole new platform to do this kind of
thing could be could be developed I'll
tell you so it really came from its two
things so I'm a program I've been
programming since I was a teenager in
high school and so you know I think when
you're programming you you have to build
logical constructs in your buying I
became you know any with any practice
right you become yeah so you can
visually uh yeah I really mastered
programming and the structure I
basically tell computers what to do for
a living and so when I started reading
these books and argumentation and debate
when I started to understand the concept
I mean what I'm talking about debate I
want a really distinguish here we are
not talking about the kind of debates we
see a presidential like haha yeah i was
just talking back and forth again
there's no substance not no substance
there's there's little substance when
compared to official like
lincoln-douglas debates so when i
started to understand the base I started
to in my mind from a programming
perspective which is databases and
websites right that a great portion got
pretty much all of the debate process
could be broken down into clear
transactions that could both be
meaningful measured aggregated and
organized in such a way
a that it actually not only gives
meaning to a debate but it allows
hundreds not thousands of people to all
contribute to the same thing yeah I can
understand you know and one of the
things that that we would do in critical
thinking classes is have students take
complex arguments and then diagram them
and so many things would fall in place
for them yeah it couldn't get it I think
a lot of it depends on what kind of a
person you are I know that I like
putting stuff up on the chalkboard
because then I can see it's actually
yeah this is really versus others yeah
yeah that's pretty much it i think it
has that potential it has that it has
the potential to do that you know when
people and people are going to see this
has eighty percent supports can't be I
don't believe it no I refuse to believe
this i've been taught otherwise as my
whole life you open it up and you read
through it and you find that one thing
that someone wrote because they grew up
in your part of the neighborhood or grew
up in your culture and they said one
thing that's going to make a difference
and then you're like you know there's
that that moment i don't think most of
us are even used to having a moment
where we knew we realized something new
moment of enlightenment yeah it's so
commonly associated with anger because
we're having it vocally and we want to
be right and we're in the moment and
we're in the heat of it that I don't
think we're even used to as a culture
2222 almost enjoying it and having a
thrill of my country it's true and
applications of something being true you
know yeah I think it's a beautiful thing
they'll be gross here's one one last
sort of you know reminiscing kind of
question then we'll get into some other
stuff and start taking some more
questions from from viewers by the way
if you want to ask us questions or leave
comments use the Q&A app in Google Plus
you can ask us anything that you wanted
about this platform about critical
thinking about culture of philosophy
about you know channels or things like
that and will will field them but here's
so here's the question I don't know if
you'll be able to answer this with any
sort of precision how much time would
you estimate that you've devoted in this
project to conceptual
sizing and then developing Wow here's
the score well let's think about it I
think it was very on and off for the
first five years um you know on and off
means I spend a couple of hours a week
I'm not doing the math here but it was
very hot it off for a couple years um
it's really in the last four years that
I I mean I have notebooks of notes that
I've created you know being on planes
and just reading and researching gosh I
guess it's just like a part-time job you
know um the equivalent of a part-time
job you know it evenings and I know if
you're looking for like hours a week or
no yeah but but it's a good long for my
mind hmm just to give some sort of
perspective to the viewers about what
goes into something yeah it takes a lot
of energy one of the things that have
learned is um people in general it
doesn't matter what the family friends
or people even know very well um you
know there's a lot of discouragement out
there and I think I've heard that from
from people who would become singers and
dancers and yeah we've become successful
there really is a lot of discouragement
it's incredible I'm scourging everyone
is not in a bad way you know but to be
able to get past that is i think is this
is necessary yeah you know what is what
I started thinking about is you probably
put as much time in truth score as I put
into my my first book which is a set of
translations and that an introduction
and bibliography and it took me about
six years right but it wasn't like you
know it wasn't all just focused on man i
was teaching and I was doing doing other
things and even writing other other
projects and then there were some
periods where that's all I would be
focused on for say a month or so right
now with with the book if you're you
know if you're a philosopher and you
have an academic position you tell your
colleagues you know I think I'm going to
do a book they say yeah that's that's a
good
yeah because you want to get tenure
looking photo shoot so there's kind of
Xena some encouragement they're doing
the kind of book that that I plan on
doing there was actually was a lot of
discouragement like you're gonna you're
gonna do what you're gonna translate
this dolphin and nobody else's is is
working with this and because I was
trying to do something you know to
promote scholarship on the set of
debates actually sort of debates about
about our philosophy and Christianity in
in France but it you know at least with
that there's there's a kind of
recognized process oh you're going to
write a book all right well you know
then you should do this and this and
this with designing something like this
who did you who did you run into who was
supportive who said yeah I think this is
a great idea run with that were there
models for you that you had four other
people who'd been successful doing this
no I mean I have my programmer pure
friends right so i have my like
close-knit a couple of friends were
programmers and they were supportive
they were supportive they were actually
the most supportive you know they didn't
quite understand it exactly like i did i
guess they didn't believe in it may be
as much but but they were supportive my
family was supportive my brother who's
probably watching I think for I don't
know for the last nine years just let me
be that maybe five years just didn't
believe it didn't believe that he just
thought I was using it as an excuse to
be obsessed with him I can compress it
and he's right I have used it as an
excuse to be obsessive about things um
but you know until he saw the website
you know I'm on my screen and he
actually saw it working and he thought
to himself oh you know he started asking
me questions about reddit he started to
like really realize that there's
potential here there's potential here
yeah there's I think there's there's
something to that having something
tangible that you can you can point to I
was actually reminded and this is like
totally off topic but it's it's kind of
funny um I'm a big fan of Dilbert and
almost everybody who's worked at an
office probably is and there's one where
the the dog who's always trying to get
out of war
work is being asked by sublimity how
come you didn't get this work done so
well I've got all these other projects
and they said well you don't get any of
these other projects done yeah cuz my
projects are good for for an excuse for
why I can't get to your practice totally
totally ya know for sure without a doubt
that's there's no doubt about that um I
think there are some people who do that
so here are there are I can if you um
because I can knock some these out at
tub you an answer consoles I'm sorry um
let's let's actually finish up with the
the forum question because there is
something I want to say no this is one
that that altavista 89 had up before we
started its truth score like a forum how
is it different than numerous forms i
can send on to you've answered quite a
bit of that yep i think that one way i
think that the thinking about a forum is
being a sort of sequential conversation
what we would call diachronic in in
linguistic terms is a good way to think
about it it flows through time right
it's a record of it just only goes one
way with this it's more like a whole
network that spreads out so that well
from one topic you can have all these
different perspectives being represented
and then those can sink even further
into the nuts and bolts of why people
believe this and so it's it's it's less
tied to time in a certain sense for sure
for sure and I can answer it 1-1 further
way you know there's no limit to how
deep truths or goes it makes me think of
the matrix um sometimes and we've heard
this we've heard lectures before where
the professor or someone's explaining
something and they make a case you know
they talked for like let's say 30
minutes they first explain a fundamental
concept a then they explain fundamental
concept be then explain cindy and at the
end they they tie it all together into
this tapestry of persuasion for through
those that are persuaded and so truth
score away form for that exact
conversation you can create an argument
that proof that proves a new idea that
connects with another argument that
proves a new idea and you can
go deeper and deeper and deeper I should
say shallower and shallower and
shallower and so you're making your case
to support a test of reality and you
know people have ready voted on that if
they think it's a good test of reality
or now we can be persuaded by that yeah
what makes it different why don't you
tell me what question you'd like to take
next and then I'll put it up on the
board since I control yeah gonna be the
911 one okay you know i'm not going to
talk extensively about it you can go to
architects and engineers for 911 truth
oh it's thousands of architects and
engineers who have you know American
citizens you know who are the
professionals in the matter there are
the ones that do the physics and you
know I don't say much about them they're
the they're the professionals at go to
court and you know courts take their
testimony as their testimony they bound
together and they've created a
compelling case that challenges the
status the you know the National
official story and so if you want to
know what I what I think really you all
you have to do is go to 911 AE 911 truth
com I believe you can google that and
you know whatever you find there I think
they're doing a great job of shining
light on something that's kind of been
closed by I think our governments close
their eyes to what else in what other
new information can be discovered there
I think so that I believe and I think I
think it's important from a critical
thinking perspective to to play out to
two things one is that one can reject
the the official you know 911 report the
book that you can buy in part in whole
you know on this reason that reason
they're not all rejections of it are you
know the same thing I don't think yeah
yeah and then you can also say well i
think you know here's a plausible
reconstruction that's very different
than saying I know exactly what would
happen the other thing is um it's an
interesting thing to ask leandro about
but it almost has nothing to do with
truth score as such other than you know
being something that that got him
thinking about it in the first place
because um you know regardless of what
position a person has on
you know particular controversial topics
it's not going to play an awful lot into
the structure or something like truth
score oh yeah my political views and my
religious views um you know they don't
get in the way of my work when I program
for my clients and then I'm gonna get in
the work in the way in the word in this
is my goal to get in the way of truth
score truth squares a platform for
everyone to communicate in and you know
I originally thought of making a case
about 911 and about other things that
are important and I realized you know I
had i've been i've been in its good at
took ten years because I've grown a lot
right in 33 now I've matured quite a bit
and I realized that when you make
something open and you give people voice
you know if you build it they will come
yeah I don't know if 911 I'm inai I have
my own personal beliefs but I don't know
what the world will ultimately decide on
911 or any kind of cop topic like that
but now you know soon at least there'll
be a platform for people to find out
yeah you know it's kind of interesting
it reminds me of that I go to this
international society for mac and tiring
inquiry which is big mouthful and it
needs is it it's a society of people who
like Alistair McIntyre's work some of
them are you know hardcore Marxist some
of them are used the world what's up you
committed human oh the UM Carl is it
curly oh yeah yeah Carl Jung yeah yeah
there's there's a huge following and I
understand yeah well here's the thing
McIntyre he's still alive right now he's
very you know he's in his 80s but he's
good help yeah he go to the meetings you
know why he does her he doesn't he
doesn't does not done it he went to one
he went to the one that was celebrating
his 80th birthday that was you know
because they were celebrating his
birthday so obviously he has to be there
he doesn't go because his view is that
if he goes people are going to be
looking to him for what's the answer and
you know heated all about he's all about
open inquiry and debate and engaging
opponents and stuff like that it's a
sort of like that with you and truth
score you know your vote should count
for you know one vote just like
everybody else's which it does
i do wanna specify that you know lest
anyone anyone think that it doesn't
because you know you created something
because you have confidence in the
process of inquiry and debate I do and
reasoning I think you know I think you
know we're all literate or most of us
we're all literate and let you say we're
all literate right it's just such a
great percentage here in the US um I
don't think we're very a lot I guess our
reasoning our ability to reason everyday
reasoning like driving a car of course
when they have a freaking complex things
down we are useless it's very insulting
to say that it's a come from a
passionate place when I say I just get
so frustrated that people can be so
easily persuaded to see things this way
or that way it's so incredible and all
you know by the way just go to any go to
most other countries you know um let's
just use Russia since that's the popular
one on topic you know we are Russian
propaganda blah blah blah blah blah but
no one considers that here it's
frustrating let's take another another
question let's not do any than 911 stuff
yes I try to suggest everyone if you're
asking questions and you see a question
you like pill please last one yeah we
know that we should ask that first go
ahead which other one would you like to
take next are you gonna pick one I think
there's just so many no which is what
knobs which is really flirt when he says
perhaps start a topic on truth score and
then quicker what what he means by by
that like show I don't know what he
means maybe draw something on the screen
I don't know Bob please rephrase your
question be more clear let's go to the
next one interval infirmary alright but
Duncan pues a question if here it is
which topic or issue would you consider
be the most urgent or important right
now the basic question that truth score
wants to answer are we talking language
games and language games of language
games or something different so two
totally different questions there and
I'll do a little bit of unpacking about
the language games thinks he's referring
to 15 Stein there so just just deal with
the first part
um you know I don't really I don't know
it's most urgent we have so many
different things like I'll tell you this
look we're all passionate about
different things so what I find most
urgent for me which is really what i
find urgent right now it wasn't what was
urgent you know a year ago so it changes
from a moment's almost like the news
watch the news oh my god it's a bowline
that's important now um so I think it
depends whatever you're passionate about
Duncan whatever you think is the most
important thing to be out there and that
you're passionate about you go out there
and you put it up because people like
you we're passionate about it will
appreciate it and they'll contribute and
people who could be enlightened in that
regard could too it's like it's the
perfect place that it's too it's very
guess it's a very personal question so I
think 911 is a good one if I was going
to give one an answer I think the
growing police state statism in general
I think is a really great topic if
you're familiar with statism um so yeah
I think actually I was going to pick one
up on the record I think statism is
would be my biggest time yeah there you
dealing with like one of the fundamental
questions of of political philosophy you
know it's really one of those sort of
you decide this and a lot of things
follow after that but you know it's how
could there be one single the way the
truth scores design how could there be
one single most important topic sense
yeah there's so many different confirms
that we have you know yeah no no one
most important yeah it's whatever you
want to make of it I'm sure there will
be trending topics i'm sure there will
be topics that will you know a lot of
people will get to see because it would
be on top it's just so popular hot yeah
but um that'll be the date for the hours
nope let's look at the second part of
his question and I'll do a little
unpacking here cuz i'm assuming he's
referring to vid concern when he brings
up language games so the idea behind a
language game is that you have a
community of people and instead of
victor shine rejected the notion of you
know sort of a logical definition
structure for things and he said the way
that you find out the way that p
use language as you actually go in and
you observe what they're doing with it
and so you know he he made up some kind
of kooky games himself and some of his
books but you know you could understand
what what people are doing in different
areas where they're using language in
very different ways as as being engaged
in separate language games and so he
says are we talking language games is
this going to be something like the
continued language games Manny's got
used trying to take it to a second level
or our language games of language games
or something different um look let me
ask you a question I have not sure if
you're done I'm trying i think i'm
understanding it does he mean will this
just turn into a big circle of talking
like without definition is that what
yeah and then there's the worry about
are you going to have communities where
they they're just so radically different
from each other in a way that they're
understanding the topics that are being
discussed that they can't yes that's
true um i found that a few years ago
through some conversation that you know
truth is personal and so uh there will
be cultures who it doesn't matter if
they join the topic that's happening
let's say in alabama like like that that
you know that group that hates
homosexuals or whatnot you know some
groups in let's say sweden or a fairly
secular open society um they're not
they're not even they don't even have
the same standards of thinking right
their fundamentals that will naturally
drive people apart there will be people
on truth score that that you will you
will probably not talk to as much
uncertain topics just because they have
fundamental beliefs that are
incompatible with yours you know a
thesis and you're so that's a little
different than what he's talking about
from from the perspective of the vic
conditioning language game you can't
even recognize why that other person is
talking so weird there's just an in
commencer ability there oh you're
twisting or you can actually see why you
disagree with somebody yeah but are you
talking about like references like like
almost a different language where you
don't know what the person is referring
to when they're speaking that's sort of
along the lines of what
worry is there when we're back on
incommensurability and I think that you
know you you you can never like
legislate that everyone shall use the
word in this way I mean unless you're
the académie française and that even the
French people don't don't you know
follow the guidance when it comes to
that um but but I can answer that a
little better than I think yeah people
agreeing on what they're talking about
is it is an important part of truth
score so you know defining things just
like a debate when you start a debate
you know they come out the definitions
if you don't agree on the definition of
a certain concept then um then it's
going to be tough for you to debate it
so yeah there we do I think as a society
as a group socially we do have to agree
on certain certain things like that like
the meaning of words so I think will
gravitate towards certain authorities
like a certain dictionary and and just
you know there'll be some word parsing
that map for sure lots of word parsing
actually some people get really really
gritty with words so it's gonna be good
not sure if I answer that question so I
apologize that's that's that's quite all
right um let's take well let's take
Bob's sort of reworking um what is the
most important thing I can get a
notorious score that's a good question
yeah it's a great question Bob um one
it'll give you an opportunity to
actually talk with people you don't
agree with it actually basically new
points of views number one you're going
to get a different set of points of
views which i think is more and more
rare these days and you're going to get
at like wikipedia where you get the one
hopefully you get the academia and you
know you get excuse me anything for a
moment what do you get out of truth is a
great question well you know you get the
opportunity to chart out what it is that
you actually leave you know Socrates so
we're going to get out of it isn't worth
living and yeah part of examining your
life is actually examining
not just what it is you believe but what
grounds do you have for believing it
there you know I cage for crazy reasons
or are they are the reasons I could
actually you know be up voted by other
reasonable people you know that's
important i think it is i think look we
now with news you know if you're if
you're a Republican not all Republicans
I'm going to generalize here please
excuse me you know generally speaking
you watch Fox News and so you and more
importantly you really look at Fox
News's as an example right you look at
Fox News as as your authority someone
who a group who has your views and you
believe are looking out for you for
example right um I watch what's going to
ultimately become its own authority on
what what's considered true or not true
but instead of it being determined by an
organization like Fox which is a certain
number of people with certain interests
truth was going to be represented by
however many people contribute so it's
really like the voice of the world
multiplied times reasoning logic and
evidence and then multiply that time
some technology right the internet
that's how I see it so what you're gonna
get out of it is if you're having that
water cooler conversation or you're at
the Christmas table or Thanksgiving
table and and you're having a
conversation with someone you know pull
out your phone type it in find an
untruth score and awe guard to start to
list all yeah the three issues that that
you already know are the issues because
you know assuming to topic that a lot of
people familiar with the person you're
talking to is and and and examine it
open it up discover something new for
for yourself or for the person you're
arguing with that would be really
interesting to do for sure I think this
could be really valuable for the other
there's websites out there for students
who are stuck in a debate class or a
critical thinking class you know pro con
and you know a lot of Mark particularly
good or interesting this could actually
I mean this is real this isn't just you
know people putting the stuff up there
you know because they've been paid to do
it this would be people contributing
because they they actually care about
these topics won't the internet for sure
yeah so i think that i think that's
that's the main
the main appeal there is to go to a
source so like snoops you know if I'm
having a conversation with someone and
it's on snoops most people i know will
read it will digest it to be like ah ok
whatever do that because oops tends to
be at least in my opinion for the few
times i've been there seems like a good
source a reputable source now snoops is
a small organization they have a limited
number of people who can contribute to
the research truth score it it's
everybody you know we're no longer
limited to what topics are being
discussed um it's whatever you want to
discuss and you're going to discuss some
that not a lot of people care about or
not alone can agree on that's how it is
and some things maybe disagreed for 30
years there may be a disagreement that
happens for 30 years because of the
available information and the way the
culture operates and then there might be
a shift in the culture where that same
topic that's literally 30 years old
assuming no one said you know it would
shift and change and society would
change people who believe those things
died you know like nowadays with
homosexuality in the u.s. it's just
harder and harder to find people who
care I saw you know a bunch of 17 18
year olds hanging out at the gas station
and one kid mentioned be there like who
cares there's just no remote you know
yeah there's not as much traction not
available and it's not available in
their hatred there's not even there it's
just empty so as the people who hate
died and i don't mean that they should
die now i'm saying until we evolve and
and and do away with you with the older
traditional views just has going to be
let's take this one by josh josh
billings yeah a humorist once remarked
as scarce as truth is the supply has
always been in excess of the demand
there may have been a serious point here
the market for truth may be less than
you anticipate any comments looking good
question let me just read it now again
to some things i always been do we end
maybe people aren't so interested in in
in truth that's possible i might be
building something that people just
don't care about they just want to hear
what's on TV and you know turn on their
toasters that the phone that you know
our phones can make
food for us now practically there so
advanced that maybe people don't care it
it's true I you know what I think I
think people are scared of the truth
because once you discover something true
that that the ramifications the truth
like that 11 is a great example you know
if if things are a little fishier than
they do official story it means things
that most people are just not willing to
deal with and I maybe I can you know in
power people who are willing to deal
with it to have a voice so yeah that's
possible this is a big big big
experiment at least for needs big yep
that's it it's an experiment this is
something pragmatic you know you don't
you don't know when you're designing
some sort of new platform or writing a
book or developing you know a technique
for something whether it's going
they get a there's a there's a whole
history of inventions that you know or
or you know ideas that came were brought
out before their time came and they just
didn't stick and then later on when
things were ready but it seems to me
that this is a time where we are where
this would get some traction where I
think so look people no I don't want to
be wrong so we naturally have this drive
to be right right it's an evolutionary
feeling so i think i think truths course
challenge will be to harness this right
wrong world yeah I sit in such a way
that actually becomes productive because
right now it's not productive at all it
just produces you know these 5050 the
the way our presidential elections
United States the two-party system and
all you know the margin they nudge the
margin right in the middle and it
there's no there's no unity if half the
country's against you right against the
other half there's there's no unity man
i want to bring unity to to what's real
it's true it's verifiable well and you
know the really the only way to produce
some sort of unity that isn't just
coercive this goes all the way back to
you know again Socrates and Plato the
only way to have a some sort of unity
that isn't coercive is through rational
persuasion yeah yeah and so if we don't
create spaces this is one of the this is
one of the reasons why I got behind this
this project when Leandro approached me
about you know helping out as a expert
on critical thinking we don't have
enough spaces for this this sort of
thing we do have MSNBC and Fox News
summoning tons and tons not only of
cable but of you know bandwidth with
people posting there you know just
reposting the stuff on Facebook and
people engaging that we don't have a lot
of forums like this that don't spin off
into you know one thing or another so
this is this is a great idea you know
maybe they'll be more truth scores maybe
there'll be other things like this too
I'll say this um people don't want to be
duped really you know if they've been
duped for a long time
they don't want to change their mind I
think um the one of the visions I've had
for truth score is in the future when it
gains traction and it can't be ignored
by the media for example magazines for
example before they publish their
article there they're journalists and
only they might have a small team of
troops or people which which goes to the
Culinary Institute of America to
question a little bit a little segue
there um they may have to you know let's
say that their article has ten real
serious points that they want to they
want to publish is true they may have to
you know delay the article for a few
days so that they can make and support
the points of the article so when the
article comes out is a little number
next to like the 10 main points which
points to a true score link where you
can actually see look this happening you
know it's sort of like what is that that
measure of influence thing that came out
several years ago what was it out yeah
and it was it wasn't very good it was
mostly or Twitter how many fourth or
ebay stop followers but you look at
higher based on Klout scores plenty yeah
I mean it was um but there were some
scandals with it too turned out you
could game the system in certain ways
yeah yeah I'd like this bad um this
would be sort of like Klout only based
on something that's a bit more
substantive you know can you you close
just based on how much how much do you
generate in these areas huh yeah up this
is based on sort of a multi-level thing
you know that's a lot of good yes let's
actually take the Culinary Institute of
America CTL that's the Center for
Excellence in teaching and learning at
the Culinary Institute of America will
truth score participants gain authority
or subject matter expert credentials
based on participation or activity not
like the mayor of something on force or
Yelp it leads but status connected
nonetheless the interest yes um if I I
think as you make judgments and as as
the community um is a language you right
um and you're making reasonable the more
judgments you make because I wanted a
second for a second and say that on
truth score you're going to judge
whether you accept a certain piece of
evidence that's one judgment you're
going to accept you're going to judge
whether you think this this logic is
constructed well you're going to you're
going to make these judgment calls and
and a lot of relevance to relevance for
sure right that's that's the reality how
relevant is it to the topic how does it
influence the topic so as a topic
becomes more mature with members of
people and it starts to to what I call
mature means in a certain direction is
revealed in its majority of people you
know if you're one of the early adopters
of it you're egging specially for the
creator of it and you're a large
contributor to it um yeah you gain a lot
of points for that and for not own
contribution points but but how rational
you are how will you need to change your
mind those are going to be tracked
throughout truth score so there may be
people who you know put in 40 hour weeks
on truth score you know doing what they
do and they're going to amass a huge
amount of energy for what they've
contributed and yeah they could even
abused their power in that way there's a
question that's that's not not in there
but but related to that and so sooner or
later as it grows you're going to need
you know like when you run into spammers
or people who are just you know trolling
and engaging in really uncivil
discussion or people who are just trying
to game the system you know um you're
going to need curators I guess you can
call them right yes oh are those going
to be the people who have high scores or
you know I pop I'm not exactly sure
meaning i don't know exactly what's
going to what what threshold we're going
to give people you know more or less
control our goal is to have it be as
bounce as we can and you know there are
so many different methods out there i
know i forgot the name of the website
all of a sudden but there are lots of
websites out there that use karma and
lot there's there's so many different
technologies to pick from and concepts
to pick from when trying to control and
help that ultimately it's gonna be a lot
of eyeballs you put one little flag flag
isn't appropriate and why with a little
few options and you know the community
will pretty
resolve itself it will be it will be
completely void of bad things but um you
know nowadays that isn't so much so much
of a problem if you think about it it
exists but an email spam is worse
anything that's better yeah yeah I even
get cell phone spam you know that's
messages like that yeah that's
technically very rarely but they come
through they squeeze them through its
incredible very rare but still make it
down if I want to get too many questions
as possible and try to be more
intentional let's take this one by brian
byrne I'm interested to know following
from my previous question what is the
difference between the truth score and
fact check model sites okay one big
difference is fact check is one
organization so you know there's let's
say 30 people who are dedicated to
putting up putting up content truth
score is is it's anyone it's infinite
and so you know fact-check you know
they're going to put something and you
know the administration doesn't want it
whether it's here or rush or some of the
country it may not go look truth square
will be like that you want to talk about
911 we want to talk about Ebola you want
to talk about cancer cures go for it now
I'm using those topics because you know
they're controversial they're the ones
are going to be up there that actually
you know I I didn't think about this but
um truth score is something that is
existing on some servers right so um how
are you going to make sure that it can't
be taken down in we're always so step up
two hacks but the Pirate Bay which is a
unfamiliar with higher pay it'll
basically it's the it's the it's the
granddaddy of bit torrents which is a
technology that allows you to download
and share files in a way that's more
difficult to track um it's like the the
that doesn't matter sorry old reference
to that music site Napster it snaps turd
well I'm not know that yeah um so they I
mean the founders are in jail
unfortunately because they um what do
they do they they their website allows
people to download web movies and move
Hollywood money right that's all
connected so um but their website has
been up through and through so you know
the internet itself wants to be we wants
to like there's providers out there
there's people out there who are willing
to go to countries and have servers in
places that you would never imagine and
it may lead to that truth score maybe a
WikiLeaks / The Pirate Bay in the sense
that it has people talking about things
that the government is want us to talk
about but you know what that's an old
battle and we're going to keep fighting
it okay we're going to keep reading our
books and we're going to keep learning
as a society regardless of what let's
take this this one 911 related one in
part because I actually have something
to say about it but you might have
something to say as well so this from
Duncan puke I have to comment on the 911
question say it's a waste of time to
investigate conspiracies a much more
fruitful to look at how it's been used
to instill fear in US since just saying
oh no you make a good point so there joe
i think what you're saying duncan is
that there's multiple topics in that
world right one of them being what
actually happened which is important to
whatever extent but more importantly is
how do they use what happened against us
or what for whatever agenda i should say
that might be there right um I agree
that's the thing that's that's the best
part you know so let's say you have six
golden topics that you can come up that
touch up on all those things they're
available and if you don't work them the
way that the you know it's going to
someone out there's going to come up
with it and so whatever you care about
whatever you think is important to be
discovered you know the platform for
people to discover it together so you
know that actually before I I say what
I'm gonna say is response to this that
actually brings up a good question if
you have two topics that are really
similar to each other is there a way in
truth score to merge those topics
together that doesn't exist right now
but that's definitely something that you
have to exist ultimately people will
want to maybe revise their topic here
you could word something in such a way
that just makes it inconvenient to talk
about because you use the wrong
word or wrong something when it comes
yeah if you they'll use planted language
that's sort of like correct yeah right
you can start a topic off just with
assumptions that don't work so so there
there that's to come of course but ways
of revising topics in that way and also
emerging which you know they never
really yeah they actually there's a
processor there's been a conversation
about that multiple conversations are
not working so for sure yes it's so to
go to that that question i would say
what you got there is a false dilemma we
don't have to pick clean being
investigated inspira sees and looking at
how conspiracies are used because it's
not as it for one individual person of
course you only have 24 hours in a day
and you gotta pick what you're going to
you're going to study I don't actually
spend a lot of time on conspiracy
theories period myself because I got
other stuff to do but if you were
interested in that sort of thing there
is no reason why person a over here
can't you know be devoting themselves
full time to looking into whether
there's a conspiracy and person B over
here be looking at the effects or how
it's being used those don't preclude
each other and ur the one for my truth
score you can help because you've got
it's it's essentially crowdsourcing you
can have people looking into all aspects
of a particular topic for me i would
actually you know personally i think
that that police militarization and you
know the development of these these very
predatory local governments that are
that are using that is a much bigger
worry for me than the 911 i'm not that
big okay i dont Ivan boat and with that
one you could also break that down to
all sorts of topics and so it's I don't
think unless you want to say unless you
want to sort of like bracket it and say
for a given person it's more effective
for them to focus on versatile yes but
if you've got platform like truth score
you can divide up the labor in the
intellectual labor in very well said
divided believers great now you'll have
a group of people trying to prove the
things about how it actually happened
and in other people trying to talk about
species affect us in intermedia they can
all be converging you know they're going
to be using one group can be using the
proves of topics from other groups
together yeah side of each other and we
you know we want to have people from as
many different positions so if some
people think that a 911 conspiracy
theories pure nonsense right whatever is
in that you know that that book I've got
it around here somewhere then you know
the 911 report gospel truth that bacon
they can create their topic I think Ian
on other ones and say I don't I don't
buy this you know that's exactly what
what you want to see happening I know
for me as somebody who who believes in
the importance of rational debate that's
what i want to see happening you know
mm-hmm agreed agreed yeah that's a lot
of potential there great question okay
let's uh let's take this other one by by
brian byrne more of a comment than a
question this is much potential it will
certainly help to remove
misunderstanding and manipulation from
debate regarding public policy it will
build the standard perhaps or am I being
too hopeful so there's that question
that yet yeah yeah yeah well I think it
has the potential to unite people so
I'll give you an example I live in it I
live in a townhouse community of 98
homes and we have an association right
now we really have elected officials
right my neighbor is one of the
officials in a sense right we we have
them do the thinking for us that they do
most of the work if you will not just
not yeah the execution is supposed but
the whole idea of representation which
is what we have in Congress and what we
have with our neighbors here with our
association so the beggar the big
version and a small version I think
truth score gives these organs groups an
opportunity to organize in a whole new
way where everyone has a voice the
people who have the most rational things
to say get hurt the most not not because
truth scores bias but because people
will naturally be drawn to the people
who who make the most rational educated
arguments that's my presumptions and so
I think we can almost
the future potentially is to create a
standard but like a new technology which
is like email email is an idea that came
to be no one monopolizes on it it's
something that's used by many
organizations Bitcoin which created as
an idea that's still very development in
development but the idea of having a
currency that's that can't be altered
that can't be debated by a government
incredible and actually Bitcoin as many
other features that said so that's a
sidebar there so I think there could be
a room for a way in which people can can
unite and everyone has a voice the
imagine of public policy was decided the
local like city policy you have an
account it's vetted as you because you
live there you pay your taxes you have
an ID or whatever and you make choices
about your your town not because the
mayor said it the mayor just execute
what the truth score community that
lives in that town decide together based
on your votes on what's most rational
yeah you know um I wasn't voted of
course in the recent election because I
don't buy the arguments that I should
cancer kid I should cast a principled
non vote because they don't count those
right um but the the process of going
and voting even in local stuff is so
demoralizing you know because like you
said so many things there already like
planned out decided ahead of time
there's no real debate as far as most of
the things go sometimes you only have
one candidate running to check it or not
you know at least New York at least here
in New York we have a lot of parties so
you can you know you can throw your vote
around different places although most of
the parties will end up endorsing the
same two candidates as it turns out
Vienna and so you know this has the
potential there's something about
actually participating by getting to say
something mmm so much there's so much
more there than going in and checking
stuff off yeah there's an engaging
aspect of it you know a website that
actually asks you do you think this is
going to make a difference in this topic
do you have it's logical do you think
this is rational do you think this is
good evidence I think computers can't
make those choices right artificial
intelligence is in the work
by lots of people computers can't make
those traces just yet but truth score
basically connects those choices that
humans can make and how they connect to
each other records them it makes use of
them yeah now you know can this remove
all misunderstanding and manipulation of
course not you know no no that's always
going to be a raffle yeah I you know
it's like any other it's like any other
thing it's a matter of sort of shaving
off some of it and changing the culture
that you know I think this has a lot of
potential to to transform the culture
that we're in and it's on the the in the
format that we're going to be living on
the rest of our life in this this
virtual you know interconnected world
wide web you know yeah to add to that is
them you know in reading these debate
books and concepts propaganda is brought
up in these debate books they talk about
because propaganda is very emotionally
and truth score is not meant to be in
motion based at all you know you can
have your emotion that's great but but
that's not what's going to carry a
conversation forward yeah and you never
do you know just use emotionally charged
language people can can tag you on that
they can they can say you know you're
committing this fallacy over here of
appeal to fear or appeal to outrage or
things like that mmm I'm Bob Swift asks
yeah can we have a peek at what truth
score looks like and I don't think we
can do that here we're not set up to do
that um so if you're interested in
taking a peek this is what I recommend
in about two weeks I'm going to be
contacting all the people who are
requesting invites if you go to WWE
escort com you can it's everyone knows
it's spelled right I'll have to spell it
um so if you request an invite you'll
get to see it so you'll do more than a
peek you'll get to see the prototype and
you get to contribute a little bit and
play around and stumble and and deal
with the fact that it is a prototype
right so you can't sit on you can't jump
on the seats because they make break but
you can drive it around just be careful
and so so that'll be available so you
can take a look then and yeah you know
what if there's a lot of demand on that
maybe I'll show some previews and it
yo upcoming i'll link it to this video
as well so that sounds great so just to
reiterate if you want an invite to truth
score you can go to the site click on
the you know aunt request an invite
button if you're watching this right now
or if you're watching this as we put it
you know out in the the canned version
contact me and row and he'll let yet
absolutely a people who are
participating here i'll give preference
to people who watch this video
afterwards they give preference to but
but after that once we have so many
people it's too much to manage for the
prototype so not first compressor all
right here's a couple other questions
this is an interesting one this from
Christophe Oh Gorman could the truth
score be used as an antidote for shock
jock radio I don't know what shock jock
radio is that's um that's the kind of
radio stuff where they are you know just
sort of throwing stuff out there to try
to bring up ratings by by talking about
controversial issues oh very good sounds
like yeah no no for sure I actually
think yeah you know I think it would be
an antidote for that but I don't let say
antidote because some people are still
into that right infotainment or is that
what it's called yeah yeah exactly look
going to be into that um and so you're
not going to pry those people away but
truth school will be this platform where
the people who are also turned on or
exclusively turned on to two more
cerebral matters um they'll have a place
to go they'll have a place to talk and
explore so I don't know if it's an
antidote per say cuz you you know i i'm
assuming just a little i know about
culture some people just don't really
care about there's apathy is a big
problem in our world going back to the
topic of whether is it a market for it
there's quite a bit of apathy in the
world so um ya know after three such
there is there's a little chicken egg
thing though to the apathy i think that
a lot of people are a pathetic because
they they just don't have any other
there there's no way for them to really
do anything engaging that that lasts for
agreed really why people have
conversations and there
like man that was a good conversation
how come I don't do this every day and
then they look around and they're like
well who the hell am I going to do that
right correct here here you get to do
that I want to add something you know I
I really imagine something in the future
where truths row becomes this and it may
not be true to itself but the process
the idea of having the internet kind of
come together about issues I imagine a
future world whether it's I can't
actually said it I said it already with
the cities but I can imagine a Congress
that actually makes decisions based on
certain policies are decided just like
we know you call Congress everyone calls
and goes crazy people are putting you
know seventy-eight percent of the
population is is he's voting and the
rationales right here what are gonna do
you can say no you know the rationales
in black and white on screen okay do you
think there will be um let's say you
know that this becomes very successful
do you think it'll inspire rival
platforms that important market it I
hope so I hope so I hope I I I hope
someone there's you know that spawns
sister sites that do similar things
maybe instead of a truth there's another
way to connect people in a meaningful
way that's never been considered about
hair or glasses I don't know sex
anything you know well yeah you can get
a lot of mileage out of out of sex as
far as controversial topics here I don't
know you know oh well [ __ ] you know
unless hair becomes identified with
something politically I guess or I want
to just ways of connecting like Bitcoin
bit couldn't be used for so many other
reasons there's so many applications for
it it's not beautiful gorgeous gorgeous
court let's take this one by Dan porno
Ordonez just one second ring I grew I
went to high school with Dan 20 10 15
years and you know he moved away I
haven't seen a long time and I miss him
and so it's really great to see him
listening and if which asking question
so go ahead there what's really cool
it's nice so there's been a lot of
controversy over the plausibility of
global warming is this the sort of thing
that truth square may shine a light on
and if so can you give us a simulation
of how truth square might deal with this
it's a good question really great
question um yeah so yeah there's a lot
of back and forth about about global
warming and I think truth scroll would
greatly contribute it would create some
clarity so there are some truths about
global warming that I think like co2
which we all know about we know what it
denies that co2 right in the air um
there's um with you the topic uh where
they spray the sky with like an aluminum
spray to reflect more light it's called
um I know someone's out there screaming
at the screen saying what it is but
there's that right there's that there's
that controversy and then it's cooling
because of the Sun now the sun goes
through i think an 80 year or a 250 your
site there's a cycle but the sun goes
through so i think the answer is yes Dan
um I mean the fact that you're asking
this question I want to make it clear
truth scores an open platform so
anything can be discussed and as long as
the topics can be shown to have rabble
relevant evidence behind them and
supports behind them and the tests of
reality can be digested and consumed by
the public by the market out there for
sure I think it's going to create
clarity and so many different areas of
our life at least that's not hope I am I
hope it has an impact that we don't
quite know yet I think that one way that
with topics like this huge big lots of
role things rolled into each other kind
of topics the fact that truth score
allows us to develop you know separate
topics as sort of arenas where things
are going to be discussed is really
important because in critical thinking
one of the things that we stress is it's
important to make distinctions where
distinctions need to be made so people
talk about global warming right and
there's you know man-made global warming
that's one question is there man-made
global warming going on is there
cyclical global warming that's another
question sometimes people blur these
together into one big phrase same thing
happens like the stem cells right Julia
lap stem cell research and you know
there's like three different questions
involved there we talked about adult
stem cells fetal stem cells right
boarded lines the right lines
you know so when we're able to say this
should be allowed or this should not be
allowed and we have to specify are we
talking about you know say government's
with the stem cells we're talking about
government support for research on fetal
stem cells making that specification
allows for a better discourse than just
saying stem cells what do you think you
know right no dig guys stem cell what do
you think doesn't work in truths grid
all but you know what you go on TV news
and that's what they'll do not pick up
the topic of the day stem cells see and
then it goes to the net that issue of
time again on TV news you're dealing
with the time format where everything's
got to be very sequential get a couple
talking heads you know let's get this
position now we'll get the counter
position each one gets their 30 seconds
and then you know you have the the news
caster at the end saying I don't know
what to make of it you know yeah that's
exactly what truth right right this you
can actually yeah this you can actually
like peruse at your leisure and say okay
here's the positions for here's the
positions against let's say actually
take a look at these you know totally
totally I mean sometimes I wish I could
just pause the record you know the TV
yeah and like pull them pull them out
and into it into the room and then grab
researchers like you know like like you
know I Dream of Jeannie kind of stuff
baby baby and actually have a
conversation about one other thing one
of the things they said one sentence
they said truths would get out let's do
that you know I think I think presidents
and i will say think things and then
they'll be untrue score within 10
minutes and they'll just be an avalanche
of things showing this is just be ass
you know this yeah this this is what he
said yesterday or whatever so um and the
Baptist Church you know I wish Duncan I
wish you would have told me the mean oh
I remember it's the Westboro Baptist
Church Westboro I know that it was
borough but I don't remember the name of
a town so I didn't I I don't yeah
unfortunately didn't remember that i can
remember that actually say they are
budding up to 7 30 and
I really appreciate you coming on for
this land row for the full hour and a
half and fielding all these these
questions I wrote you know it's been a
very fun dr. sailor philosophy form i
think this fits in really well with the
whole world philosophy day theme which
was about you no dialogue so thank you
for having me i thought it's great it
went by so quickly uh yeah i'm gonna
leave this open right this is this is
just the first conversation that i'm
having about this and i hope i can have
more it not here somewhere else do
you'll come on again some other time I
would love to I'm not okay that sounds
great let me put in one plug before we
end I actually have a new YouTube
channel that I started up I think about
three weeks ago two weeks ago yeah
typically on critical thinking logic and
argumentation right now there i think
there's about 10 or 11 videos in there
because I'm releasing you know one every
every day or every other day all the
ones I've got right now are the
fallacies but if you if you've been to
my normal youtube channel that is about
550 videos now you know that I'm going
to keep churning this stuff out and
there'll be a lot of series on topics
I'll have you know things on specific
things like what are the different
fallacies or what reasoning or deductive
reasoning but i'll also be discussing
you know things that are books that are
very important for say logic like
Perlman's new rhetoric you know this is
just chock-full of different forms of
arguments and i'll be giving that the
same sort of paragraph by paragraph
treatment that i'm doing in the half
hour Hagel series so it's educational
right you're really do break it down
anyone interested in those topics not
exactly yeah i mean that's another great
thing with youtube in that platform if
you're not into this sort of thing will
you go somewhere else and you watch the
cat videos or you know you know people
say why don't you do it you know they'll
get on an angle video why aren't you
doing video about Kent will go over
there look at the con videos then you
know anybody can see whatever they want
to yeah that's the best part that's it
you know let the passion speak for
themselves yeah alright well we'll wrap
this up
thanks Leandro for for coming on there's
a great conversation I want you have the
last word um sign up that's my last word
request an invite please I need as many
people as I can to make this happen
everyone contribute together thank you
guys